what if i told you there is a database
that is 100 free
has a world-class admin ui and almost
everybody in the world knows how to use
it that's impossible believe it or not
google sheets the spreadsheet software
can be used as a lightweight database or
headless cms
as the data layer in your application
stack and that's exactly what i'll show
you how to do today
by integrating google sheets with nexjs
in the process you'll learn how to
easily fetch data from a google sheet
in any server side node.js application
which also opens the door to connecting
hundreds of other google apis to your
server
if you're new here like and subscribe
and follow along with the full write-up
on fireship i o
but before you get too excited about
this amazing old tech there are some
important caveats when using google
sheets as your primary database
first of all it was never designed to be
an app database it's not going to be
acid compliant
and doesn't support joins or complex
queries actual data storage only scales
to 5 million cells
and there's also an api quota that
limits you to 500 requests per 100
seconds
but even with those limitations google
sheets actually makes a great little
database for prototyping
and there's really nothing stopping you
from using it in production if you're
building a jam stack site you could use
it as a headless cms and it's very
unlikely that you'll ever hit the api
quota or storage limits but most
importantly
it's super easy to use so let's jump
right into things the first step
is to create a google sheet and add some
data to it you'll notice i have two
columns here
one for the title and one with content
in the form of html
now to fetch or query data from the
sheet all you have to do is highlight it
and you'll notice when you do that
that it creates a range of cells up here
in the top left corner that'll come into
play later when we start making requests
through the api
now in order to make the sheet available
to the app we need to share it publicly
when you click the share button
it generates a url and inside that url
you'll notice an id
which is the id of the sheet itself
you'll want to make a note of that id
for later the next step
is to generate our next js application
and keep in mind
you can follow the same basic process
for any node.js server
we can run npx create next app from the
command line
and then open it up in vs code whenever
working with a google api on the server
you'll want to install the rest client
for your preferred language which in our
case is node.js
run npm install google apis and we can
use this package to simplify the
authentication process
and give us intellisense and bs code now
what we actually want to build in next
is a blog
that will give us a list of post titles
then clicking on a title
will take us to the post page and render
out the html in the google sheet
that means we need two different
components in next which will live in
the pages slash post directory
the first one is the index page and the
second one takes a dynamic id parameter
which corresponds to an actual row in
the spreadsheet
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
these files empty because before we can
do anything
we need to authenticate the google api
to our project
authenticating a google api in a project
is a very complicated topic which you'll
find out
if you try to read the official
documentation but it doesn't really have
to be there are multiple ways to
authenticate but the two you should know
about
are application default credentials and
oauth 2.
in this demo we'll be using default
credentials which is just like using an
api key
the limitation though is that you only
have access to resources on your own
google account that works fine for us
but many apps using google apis want
access to
resources owned by other users like for
example if our app wanted to access
files in somebody else's google drive
for apps like that the other user needs
to first give us permission
and the only way to do that is with
oauth 2 authentication
that's beyond the scope of this video
but it's important to make the
distinction
and if you want to learn more i have a
pro video on fireship io dedicated to it
now that we decided we're using default
authentication we can head over to the
google cloud platform console to enable
the api
now the sheets api is 100 free but you
may need to have a credit card on file
when creating a new google cloud account
once you have a google cloud account and
project set up you can go to apis and
services
then click the button to enable apis and
services type sheets into the search bar
then click the enable button
that'll take a second to enable then
click manage from there you'll see a tab
for credentials
go ahead and click on that and find your
app engine default service account
go ahead and click on that and then
you'll find one more tab for keys
from there you can generate a key which
is just a json file that includes your
credentials
and can authorize another server to
access apis and other resources that you
own on google cloud i'm downloading that
file to the root of my next js project
as secrets.json but it's very important
that you don't expose this file publicly
if someone gets a hold of it they'll
have access to your google cloud account
so make sure to add it to your git
ignore file before committing this to a
public repo
now that our credentials are in place we
need to make them available to our
server side code and the way we can do
that
is with an environment variable the next
js framework will automatically find any
environment variables that you define
in the dot env.local file create that
file then
inside of it add the google application
credentials environment variable
and point it to the service account json
it's important that that variable has
that exact name
in addition i'm also adding a sheet id
environment variable
which is the sheet that i got from the
url in the google sheet earlier
and now we're finally ready to write
some javascript code we'll first go into
the post id.js file and
import google from the google apis
package now the next thing i'll do is
set up our server side code
by exporting an async function called
git server side props
if you're not familiar with next js i do
have a video about that
but basically this function will only
run on the server and its purpose
is to fetch data or props that we can
then use in the front end react
component so first we'll fetch the title
and content for a given row on the
server
then take that data and render it out in
the browser or client as
html to access google sheets on the
server we need to
authenticate the api client that can be
done by awaiting
google auth git client and selecting the
scope that you want access
to which in this case is the
spreadsheet's read only scope
that's going to look for that google
applications environment variable that
we defined earlier to authenticate us
we can then use the returned object to
access the google sheets api
by passing it as the auth param and now
we're ready to make our first query to
the spreadsheet or database i mean
we want to fetch an individual row
number which we'll get from the url
as the id parameter then to make the
request we need to specify
a range of columns and cells the google
sheets query language will first have
you specify
a sheet or table followed by an
exclamation point
than the range of cells that you want to
access for example
if we want row 23 we can say column a23
through column c23
but in this case we don't want to hard
code it we want to use the dynamic id
that gets passed in through the url
now we can make an actual request to the
api by awaiting the sheets
spreadsheet values get method that
method will take our range
along with the spreadsheet id which if
you remember earlier we set up as an
environment variable that will give us a
response that contains the data we want
for the ui
the data is formatted in an array and
i'm using destructuring here to give the
values a name of title
and content now at this point we can run
the next app by running npm run dev
and if we pull it up in the browser and
go to the url of post slash
3 it should give us row 3 in the
spreadsheet and that's what i would call
some next level sheet